Donald Trump himself
in one term is responsible for roughly
25 percent of the entire national debt
of the United States a man who in like
2015 or 2016 prior to being elected to
office gave an interview with Bob
Woodward at the Washington Post and made
the Bold claim that he was going to pay
off the entire national debt inside of
eight years and instead he's now
responsible for 25 percent of the
overall debt but you wouldn't know that
if you only watched Fox News
if your parents are people who watch Fox
News is your grandparents are people who
watch Fox News they'll buy this Hook
Line and Sinker the same way Americans
bought the trickle-down economics Works
Reaganomics oh it's a godsend that's how
that's how you build back a strong
economy
it's all lies